um
so in particular if you look at the way
multi-class classification works in
machine learning
typically it's order k so if you're
choosing amongst k different things you
have an order k computation to do
and that's odd because information
theoretically you only need an order log
k
operation
right so
you'll need to specify log k bits in
order to specify
what you're trying to predict
so
um you know there's an exponential gap
between k and log k so this is the ratio
of k over log k here
it's it's it's a big ratio
it's a approximately linear
and
and now there's a question of why are
people using algorithms that are
exponentially slow
right
i mean
why are why do we use multi-class
algorithms that are exponentially slow
okay so um when you discuss this
there's several um
ideas people have for
how to address competition complexity
one of them is oh maybe in all of the
multi-class problems we care about
there's some pre-existing hierarchy
and uh
and that's that's often true there is
some sort of hierarchy people have like
for example imagenet is a good example
let me go back up a little bit right so
imagenet is
a big vision data set which is about
here in terms of the number of classes
but more generally you could think of
search which would be about there in
terms of the number of classes
right so anytime you're choosing amongst
a very large set of things
you might
maybe this should actually be thought of
as a multi-class prediction problem
so i'm thinking about both the training
time and the in the prediction time both
of those are important
and and
okay so i think uh the distinction
becomes a little bit important sometimes
when you're looking at things in uh that
people have done sometimes people create
that they have an order k training time
to create an order log k evaluation time
that's okay when k is when k is not too
large
but when k becomes larger then your
training time had better be order log k
as well
right so in the end you need order log k
for both
okay so sometimes you have a
pre-existing hierarchy and that's nice
sometimes you're doing structured
prediction so
you're thinking about doing part of
speech tagging and you can think of the
sequence of tags for each of the
individual
uh words in your sentence as is one very
complex label right
that's sort of another version of
of a of a pre-existing hierarchy
and then of course there's decision
trees decision trees are naturally
logarithmic time
okay now
somehow these
aren't adequate
and one way to look at this and say that
it's not adequate is when you think
about
really big scale problems like
search
um
it's not actually a decision tree which
is being used to figure out what to get
displayed to a first order approximation
there's some sort of keyword matching
inverted index which does things this
machine learning which comes in all over
the place around the sides but it's
really the inverted index which is
pulling up the results that the machine
learning gets applied to at a relatively
small scale
so
um
so what is going wrong here so if you
have a pre-existing hierarchy
okay so
now there's a question of are you a
machine learning person or or not right
because if you're a machine learning
person then you would like to not
actually use a pre-existing hierarchy
you'd like to be able to infer a
hierarchy and maybe you could actually
infer a hierarchy which is better than
something that somebody engineered
right that would be nice um
structure prediction is nice but maybe
you don't actually know how to structure
things
maybe there is no natural parse order
like imagine that you're
trying to uh predict the components of
an image right so uh people do parse
images but the order in which they parse
images is rather uh ill-defined and so
you could try to engineer in these
things but
maybe if we're real machine learning
people then we hope that
we can actually do it better than some
sort of pre-engineered type system
and then of course the decision trees
and decision trees are actually pretty
compelling in a lot of ways because how
else are you going to get logarithmic
time
but there's something kind of funny
about decision trees most of the
implementations of decision trees don't
actually deal with a large number of
classes that well
right so most decision trees are i mean
many of them are just for binary
prediction but some of them can deal
with small
small k multi-class classification but
often they kind of break down when you
start going to hundreds or thousands of
classes
and maybe that's partly a matter of the
features or maybe that's partly
a matter of exactly what they're
optimizing internally
okay so
sikkim is a conference for
knowledge
engineering
these are my responses um
so
yeah so
yeah i've never never pulled a straight
bert sicum it maybe it's a good
conference but uh um i i want to do
machine learning i'm trying to find a
machine learning solution to this kind
of problem
i believe that the data should lead the
way basically and i want to do as little
engineering as possible
when you look into structure prediction
you discover that
if you want to show that you're going to
get good performance you either need to
show that you have access to specific
models um
of how the world behaves
or uh some sort of optimal policy which
can demonstrate how things behave
but in many such situations you have
neither
and now that's kind of a frustrating
barrier that you're trying to get around
okay so
so again why why don't we have this
exponential speed up
okay so hypothesis number one
would be that it's not possible
and
let me show you an example why you might
think it's not possible
suppose you have three classes
suppose the probability of class one is
four the probability of class two is
point three probability of class three
is point three
and then you have a a decision tree of
this sort where you have a two versus
three node and you have a one versus two
versus three node
and then you use divide and conquer
right so we say ah is the
uh
label one or is it two or three
and now
we ask what happens to the optimal
predictor here right so
the probability of one is point four and
the probability of two or three is point
six
and that means the optimal predictor
will choose two or three
and that says that you lose
right so maybe this is the reason why we
don't do
multi-class classification in
logarithmic time
it's not consistent we don't actually
get the right answer
it turns out this can be fixed
it's a simple fix
the simple fix is
instead of learning
one versus two and three first we learn
two versus three first
so if you learn two versus three first
then you know two and three or each have
probability point three it doesn't
really matter which one you choose
uh you choose one of them and then
we have a classifier here
so we're going to keep all the examples
that the classifier agrees with
for training up here
so instead of training on
all the twos and threes we train on
either the twos or the threes depending
on what our classifier predicts
and now
the probability of label one is going to
be point four and the probability of two
probability of the winner of two and
three
is going to be
point three
so it's point four point four versus
and that means that the classifier that
we learned at the root is going to
prefer label one
okay so this is the core essence of why
you can actually
it says that you can in fact learn
statistically in a logarithmic time
predictor
and you can improve a regret bound you
can prove that the
average binary regret over the nodes
that you learn times the depth of the
tree bounds the multi-class regret
so this is a notion of regret which is
to be strong i'm comparing myself to a
baseline which is
essentially called the bayes optimal
classifier it's the one that you get if
you uh don't have any constraints on
representation
that yeah
it's not really an entropy
it's it's more a depth of the tree so if
you look at the proof
what happens is you end up adding up the
regrets at each level in the tree
yeah so if you
if you do a more refined proof you'll
have an average depth
that's true so it is very related to
entropy but not exactly the same
okay so now maybe the reason that we
don't use logarithmic time prediction is
because of that log k
right uh i mean we don't really we don't
want to have a regret be multiplied by
log k that's a bad thing
maybe trees just inherently have a
larger
error rate because you have multiple
opportunities to fail as you as you walk
down the tree
okay so
can you make it more robust that's the
basic question
so this is a binary tree on eight labels
that has one winner
and now
the green is another binary tree
on eight labels which has
a winner
and then the blue
is another binary tree on eight labels
which has a winner
okay so let's go back
so if i want to make things robust i
need to be doing some sort of error
correction that's pretty clear
i told you that depth is sort of the
critical parameter here
what is the depth required in order to
uh
do three binary trees on eight labels
you might think that it's three times
log base two of eight right so that'd be
nine
but if you look here it's actually one
two three four five six seven
so i shaved off two
and this construction goes is much more
impressive if you start drawing much
larger graphs but then of course it's
much harder to read
so in general it turns out that it's
possible
to have
uh
log
k
distinct tournaments
on k things with depth order log k
that's kind of cool
that means that you can prove something
you can prove that
uh if you have a log k correcting
tournament
the multi-class regrets will be bounded
by the average binary regret times about
5.5
so this is a constant rather than a log
okay so i didn't quite finish what
happened so you have three winners here
but once you've reduced the uh
the set of k possibilities to a set of
three possibilities or more generally
log
uh okay possibilities then you can do
something much more robust and hardcore
on that last last log k
and then everything still works out
okay so this is
interesting
um i haven't seen it be useful yet
except
at a nice email 2012 we were running the
best paper award and the area chairs
were the nodes
right
that actually worked pretty well um so
it's a nice way to kind of distribute
competition across distributed decisions
across a bunch of different people in a
robust manner
okay so this says that you can have
things that are robust
so we can be both statistically sound
and we can be robust
and now the question is
why aren't we doing things in
logarithmic time
so one answer might be that uh
programming this is a little bit
annoying but in fact i did program this
up it's in vocal wabbit you can
experiment with it
um
people still aren't using it that much
and why not
this kind of thing's handy
but uh but you know i'm trying to solve
machine learning not best paperwork
picking okay
there's another problem which comes up
which has to do with our notion of
regret we're looking here at
at a pretty hardcore notion of regret
it's it's regret respect to
the
representation independent best
classifier
and we're looking at regret here respect
to our representation independent
multi-class classifier
representation independent is not
actually what we often work with often
we work with a constrained
representation like linear prediction or
something like that
and when you when you're working with a
linear prediction
uh
there can be
classifications which just don't work
that well so think about
suppose you're going to try to do digit
recognition
right so you and you could you could
split
four labels in two different ways you
could have one and seven versus three
and eight
or one and eight versus three and seven
which one's better
so one kind of looks like seven
three kind of looks like eight
one doesn't look like eight three
doesn't look like seven
you can see how there's some sort of
similarity preserved here but not there
so is it better to have
a split but it's not clear not that
obvious which is going to be best
because
maybe you want to have an easy decision
at the top and then you want to have a
hard decision between one and seven
or maybe
you want to have a hard decision at the
top and then an easy decision between
one and eight
which do you actually prefer
so this is basically settled
uh
this is bingio weston and granger
had a paper where they showed
empirically that's just better to
confuse labels near the leaves
better to deal with confused predictions
near the leaves than near the root
and the intuition for this
is that
the root of a tree
is highly constrained
and that means that it's actually quite
hard for it to predict well um
and so you want to you want to relieve
the constraint at the root
uh while you know i had a node just
beneath the just above the leaves
it's only deciding between two things
there's not that much of a constraint
even if it's a pretty hard problem it
can sort of nail that pretty well
okay so now now there's a bit of an
issue because uh because of the question
you asked earlier um
are we trying to do an order log k
training time when order k training time
if you're trying to figure out
which classes are easily confused or
which sets the classes are easily
confused you could easily run up to even
order two to the k running time if you
wanted to look at all partitions
right
and in order two to the k would be
disastrous and order k would be
disastrous
so we really want to get order log k
training time
and now the question is how do we even
deal with this confusion problem
uh when when we want an order log k
prediction training time
okay so um
so we need to think a little bit about
what we actually are trying to do
because at
a root at a node in the tree
a node in a tree or a node in a dag
we're not trying to solve a full
multi-class problem
we're just trying to solve a piece of
the problem
and we want a set we want a piece of a
problem with property that it will
compose to allow us to solve the overall
problem
and and that it's relatively tractable
right
so
this is a definition of the partitioning
problem
so what is partitioning
partitioning is when you have a bunch of
different labels
and now you want to partition between
one set of labels and another set of
labels
but you don't know what that partition
is in advance
okay so that's kind of a strange thing
uh for a long time i thought that this
was just fundamentally different from
classification
um so here's one way to try to formalize
what partitioning means
you can say look i have a partitioner h
and
i'm going to measure the quality of this
by looking at
the expectation over my data set of okay
so this is
the probability that my partitioner
predicts label
this is the probability that my
prediction predictor predicts label 1
given that
that the example
comes from
has a particular label
okay so um
if
every
if this number is the same as this
number
so
everything is kind of split randomly
essentially
then this is zero
so that's not good
we're trying to maximize this value a
good partition is what we're just going
to maximize this value
so what we want is
all of the labels
all of the examples of a particular
class go to either one side or the other
so we want this number to be
either 0 or 1 and we want this number to
be 0.5
that would be a really good outcome
okay so this is this is a strange
optimization because this is
very inherently non-convex
so if you if your
hypothesis class is symmetric
which essentially everything that we
work with is
then uh
you know you have a solution
like this and like that and they each
have the same quality
but the average of these two solutions
may have a very poor quality in fact it
has value zero
okay so
that's kind of disturbing
can we actually optimize this that's an
important question
and and more importantly and also does
this actually work
um
if we optimize this do we actually end
up getting a good solution
okay so
because we thought about the filter
trees it's natural to think about
a bottom-up approach to trying to
construct these uh these partitions
right
it turns out that
it doesn't work
um we don't know how to construct things
bottom up and in fact it seems uh very
difficult so suppose we're looking at
linear representations so we're
representation constrained we're doing
linear representations and we want to
build a tree on these three labels right
and let's suppose these labels are in
fact on a line just as they're
represented here and suppose that we
choose
one and three and we build a predictor
so this is easy we can predict one
versus three very well
and then we build another predictor
two versus one versus three
and that's not going to work very well
because you can't linearly separate
between
two and one or three
okay so it's just like a it's a you lose
type situation so it seems like
bottom-up construction is just not
feasible at least i don't see how to
make bottom-up actually work
okay so that says that we need to
perhaps build our partitions top down
uh
and now there's kind of a question about
whether or not the partitions that we
build top down
actually will compose to give us a good
solution
right every individual node is trying
we're trying to solve a partitioning
problem
and
we want to know that if we solve a bunch
of positioning problems going down some
tree or some dag do we end up with a
good solution
and the answer ends up being yes what
you can prove is essentially a boosting
statement you can say that
if i manage to partition well at each
node
then
after i do something like this many
splits
uh the multi-class error rate that i'll
get is
less than epsilon
okay so this is this seems like a lot
it's important to take a log when
thinking about this number
uh gamma here is uh
is how well you're
you're doing your splits
and and now there's there's two things
about this theorem which are
which are worth pointing out there are
uh
there are other um
boosting statements for
um for tree construction
this is a similar statement to those
with two kind of caveats one of them is
we have a for all y here
which is bad that's strengthening the
quantifiers for the if part
um so we're supposing that we actually
managed to
decide relatively well for each
individual class
um
and then we have a log k
and the log k is pretty cool because
uh
you would like the depth of the tree to
be logarithmic in the number of classes
which is uh
not achieved by
all the other multi-class boosting
statements that i know about
okay so
so now there's the question about how we
actually find these partitions so you
could of course use guess and check
right i mean you could
just guess a partition train evaluate
guess check
over and over again
but
it's much more tempting to try to make
some sort of more efficient algorithm
because the problem that we're concerned
with is efficiency
and if you try to look at efficient
optimization algorithms and off you're
looking at online algorithms
and now what i'm going to do is i'm
going to twist the problem a little bit
i'm essentially going to use a ramp law
so what i mean here is i'm going to
think about linear prediction
and what i'm what i'm going to be
thinking about here is
something which
has a value as small as -1 and as large
as one in between those values it's
going to be w dot x right so if you take
a
a max with minus one and a min with one
so this is a continuous relaxation of
the optimization criteria and the the
the partition uh definition that i was
talking about before
okay so now we can try to create an
algorithm
uh
and how we're going to do this so we're
going to keep track of
so we have these this
an expectation for all of our examples
we have an expectation conditioned on y
so those are going to be started at
value 0 and value 0. we keep track of
the numbers we can get the expectations
right
and now for each example we're going to
run through and if
uh one side is preferred then we're
gonna set a binary label of minus one
and otherwise we're gonna set a binary
label to one
and then we update w using
a binary labeled
example
so when i started out on this i was
thinking that
this problem of finding a good partition
is not really very relatable to
uh
to classification it seemed like it was
just kind of a different problem
but here what i'm doing is i'm
essentially reducing the partitioning
problem to a binary classification
problem
so i can reuse my existing
binary classification algorithms
okay so then we do some some bookkeeping
we keep track of the count and we
change our expectation to to match the
actual true expectation
and then we
apply this recursively to every node in
the tree to construct a tree
so now the question is does this work
um
so here's a a problem this is not a real
problem this is kind of an acid test
right so you have a hundred classes
which are arranged in a two-dimensional
grid
and you just unleash the algorithm on it
right so each of these classes is drawn
from a gaussian
these gaussians are imperfectly but
nearly separated and and you just go
so if you run this algorithm on that
data set
we've got our test error rate of very
small
right so
something is going right here if you're
doing a bottom-up construction our air
rate would be near one and we would be
losing since we're doing the top down
we're actually succeeding fairly well
okay so another question you could ask
is how good is the partition that we're
creating
if you look in particular at the root of
a tree it's essentially a binary
classification problem there which is
get everything to the left
on the left and everything to the right
on the right
so if you look at the partition that we
create
it has a binary classification error of
0.1253 on imnis which is 10 classes
and if you look at random partitions
then
they don't do much better
so the average error rate is much higher
and there's some standard deviation
which occasionally does as well and if
you look at rcb1 which has 100 classes
about 100 classes
we're doing there's an even bigger gap
so this online partition construction
process that we're using
is actually fairly effective
okay so now uh if we compare with one
against all in these data sets it seems
like
it
it works but it's one of these trade-off
things um we're getting performance
which is not as good in terms of of test
error
but which of course is radically better
in terms of computation
so
uh
i think what's biting us there is
essentially the log k right there's
still log k ways to go wrong and we need
to actually fix that to do better
okay so i'm i'm done there's a workshop
at nips on this subject there's a lot of
other people who have become interested
in this kind of problem
uh there's a bunch of other issues that
i didn't really discuss one thing which
comes up is
the state is not logarithmic for the
kinds of algorithms that i was talking
about you'd really like the state to be
logarithmic as well
and uh
and then
you also want to be able to deal with
label-dependent features in many natural
settings
other questions